le ministre britannique de la défense et
à kiev on retrouve justement sur place
notre envoyé spécial pauline godard
bonjour à vous pauline cette visite qui
est bien évidemment bien reçu du côté
ukrainien
oui le ministre de la défense est arrivé
vous le dis aujourd'hui à kiev pour une
visite de deux jours il a rencontré
volodymyr zelensky le président
ukrainien qui l'a remercié pour ce
soutien essentiel que son pays apporte à
l'ukraine les mots se transforment en
actes sion c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre les relations entre
l'ukraine et le royaume uni est celle
entre l'ukraine et d'autres pays a
ajouté le président ukrainien une façon
d'envoyer un message clair une pique on
peut le dire à d'autres pays européens
sans les nommer armes finances sanctions
dans ces trois dossiers le royaume-uni
montre son leadership le message est
vraiment très clair du côté du président
zelensky vous le savez le royaume uni
fournit actuelle actuellement des
équipements des formations mais aussi de
nombreuses armes aux forces du
craignaient les le ministre de la
défense britannique et là aussi bien
pour savoir de quoi a besoin ont besoin
les forces du craignent-elles pour
continuer à combattre les forces russes
les autorités ukrainiennes ont ces deux
réclament sans cesse des armes aux
occidentaux notamment ces derniers jours
des armes de longue portée le chef
adjoint de renseignement militaire
ukrainien s'est d'ailleurs exprimé
aujourd'hui il a dit que kiev avait
presque épuisé toutes ses munitions jeu
le site et il demande une nouvelle fois
aux occidentaux des armes de longue
portée voilà pour la visite du ministre
britannique de la défense à kiev c'est
qui se fait attendre pauline et bien
c'est toujours la visite d' emmanuel
macron en ukraine
où il ya beaucoup de spéculations autour
de 2,7 po cibles potentielles visite d'
emmanuel macron pour le moment l'elysée
ne confirme rien du tout l'elysée dit
jusque cette visite en ukraine je cite
un se rédoudre se déroulera à une date
qui n'a pas été encore fixée
au moment où elle sera utile au
président élèves qui ce qui est sûr en
tout cas c'est qu emmanuel macron se
rendra dans la région puisque dit il
sera en roumanie les rats notamment voir
les troupes françaises qui sont
stationnés puis il se rendra mercredi en
moldavie pour apporter son soutien à ce
pays qui est directement touchée par les
conséquences de la gare en ukraine merci
beaucoup pauline goda envoyé spécial de
france 24 en ukraine